Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain the American comedy-drama film
called “The Truman Show.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Truman Burbank leads a quiet and peaceful life
in Seahaven island, his birthplace. He is married
to a nurse named Meryl and works as an insurance
salesman. One day, as he is heading to work after
greeting his neighbors across the street with his
traditional greeting, "Good morning! And in case I
don't see you, good afternoon, good evening, and
good night", a strange object falls from the sky
and lands near his car. He tries to ascertain
where it came from but doesn’t find any answers
as the sky is clear and the object seems like
a studio light. He brushes it aside and drives
to work. On his way to work, the radio reports
that an aircraft flying over the Seahaven island
shed its parts, which makes him believe
it was the source of the object.
At work, he makes a secret call to Fiji and asks
for information about a woman named Lauren/Silvia
Garland. When he fails to find any information,
he leaves to close a deal on Harbor Island for
his boss Lawrence. However, his fear of open
water gets to him, and he returns home.
Later, he meets his childhood best friend Marlon
and confides in him his wish to leave everything
behind and move to Fiji. Ever since Truman
was a child, he wished to explore the world,
but due to one thing or another, he never
got to go beyond Seahaven island.
After Marlon leaves, Truman sits by the beach
alone and remembers a boating accident because
of which he lost his father, Kirk Burbank. On that
fateful day, Truman’s father wanted to return from
home early due to the bad weather, but Truman
insisted on staying out at sea for a bit longer.
Lo and behold, a strong storm hit their boat,
and Mr. Burbank got swept overboard and drowned.
As Truman snaps out of his memory, a strange
thing happens. It begins to rain but only on him.
He stands up in astonishment, and it begins
to rain everywhere. He rushes home and shares
his plans about moving to Fiji with Meryl, but
she dismisses the idea, citing their financial
obligations and plans to have a baby.
The next day, Truman runs into a homeless
man on the street who looks just like his
father. But before he could talk to the man,
a number of people and obstacles show up, and the
man is dragged into a bus and taken away. Truman
shares the incident with his mother, but Mrs.
Burbank dismisses it as Truman’s imagination.
She tells him that she too sees Mr. Burnbank
in strangers sometimes, and it is normal.
That night, Truman goes into his basement and
looks through his old personal belongings hidden
away in an old trunk. The trunk contains pictures
of his childhood and a red ladies’ sweater with a
pin that says, “How will it end?”. The sweater
takes him back to his college days when he saw
a beautiful young woman named Lauren Garland while
playing in the homecoming band with Marlon. Before
he could court her, Lauren disappeared, and over
time, Truman got romantically close to Meryl.
However, one evening, Truman again runs into
Lauren in the library. He approaches her,
but she tells him that she’s not allowed to speak
with him. Despite this, Truman, smitten by her,
asks her if she’d go out with him on the weekends.
However, she tells him that she can only go out
now, and the two try to head out of the library
secretly. The cameras in the library lose them
for a second but eventually capture them running
out together through an alternative exit.
The pair make out on the beach, but suddenly a
vehicle approaches them, causing Lauren to panic.
She tells Truman that her real name is actually
Sylvia and tries to tell him the truth about
“The Truman Show.” As the man, claiming
to be Mr. Garland tries to drag her away,
Lauren tells Truman that everything and everyone
around him is fake and part of a reality TV show.
The man calls Lauren “schizophrenic” and
takes her away, announcing that they are
moving to Fiji. Truman watches in confusion
with the red sweater that Lauren left behind.
After he returns back to reality, Truman pieces
together scraps of magazine pages to create a
collage of Sylvia’s face as he remembers it.
The next day, on his way to work, the radio
malfunctions and oddly reports every movement he
makes as if he is being watched. Soon, the radio
again starts playing music after apologizing
for picking up the police’s frequency.
Paranoid, Truman rushes into a random building to
catch the people conspiring against him slipping.
As he heads towards an elevator, he is
surprised to see what seems to be a TV studio
filled with people wearing
headphones and eating lunch
instead of an elevator car. Before he could
wrap his head around what he is seeing,
the security arrives and kicks him out
for trespassing. Confused, he meets Marlon
and tells him about the strange occurrences.
However, Marlon dismisses it as his imagination.
Nevertheless, Truman confides in Marlon that
he is going to go away for a while.
When Truman returns home, he finds his mother and
Meryl watching old photos of them while on the TV,
a show called ‘Show Me the Way to Go Home’ is
playing. It seems everyone is indirectly trying
to dissuade him from going on an exploration.
Truman suddenly notices his wedding picture,
where Meryl has her fingers crossed, implying
that Meryl didn’t marry him truthfully.
The next day, Truman proceeds to travel to Fiji
but learns that there are no available flights
for at least a month. He then catches a bus to
Chicago, but the bus breaks down before it even
gets to leave the station. Meryl returns home
from work and finds Truman sitting in his car.
He invites her to sit next to him and
correctly predicts a chain of events-
a lady on a red bike, a man with flowers,
and a Volkswagen beetle with a dented fender.
He claims that everything around him
is scripted, but she dismisses him.
As she proceeds to leave, Truman locks the car
door and starts driving around spontaneously
to prove his theory. He proceeds to drive out of
the island, but the fear of open water takes over
him, and he stops on the bridge which connects
Seahaven island to the rest of the country.
Determined to leave, he shuts his eyes
and slams his foot on the accelerator,
forcing Meryl to drive. They successfully
cross the bridge and continue on their journey,
but they are soon forced to stop by police just
before a nuclear power plant that seems to have
had a meltdown. A police officer orders him to
retreat but accidentally calls Truman by his first
name despite having never met him before.
Convinced of foul play, Truman attempts
to run out of the island, but the men
capture him and send him back home.
Back at home, Meryl tries to convince him
that everything is fine, but Truman gets
even more paranoid. Suddenly, Marlon appears
at the door and takes Truman out for a beer.
Marlon assures him that everyone is not conspiring
against him. Marons further adds, if everyone did,
he would have to be a co-conspirator, too, but
he can never lie to his best friend. It is then
revealed that a man named Christof is feeding
these lines to Marlon through an earpiece.
Marlon then reveals the real reason he brought
him over for beer, and a man then appears from
the mist. It is revealed to be the homeless
man that Truman was convinced is his father.
It turns out he was right. It is Mr.
Burbank who Marlon found on the island.
The father and son embrace as Christof instructs
his camera crew to beautifully capture the moment.
Mr. Burbank tearfully promises his son
to make up for the time they lost.
It is finally confirmed that Truman is the star
of the most popular live show in TV history called
“The Truman Show.” Unbeknownst to him, Truman’s
hometown, the Seahaven island, is a massive TV set
surrounded by a dome that produces sophisticated
effects and imagery to mimic the sky, weather,
and temperature of the real world. The
dome is run by a huge staff under the
command of the eccentric Director Christof.
In an interview, Christof reveals Kirk Burbank is
not the first one to enter the show without being
a part of the script, and there have been several
attempts by fans to meet Truman. It is also
revealed that Christof previously killed Kirk’s
character to implant fear of water in Truman so
he wouldn’t think of leaving the island. Truman's
birth was a case of unwanted pregnancy, and he
was the first child to be adopted by a corporation
for a TV show. The show runs 24\7 and generates
revenues by product placements. While taking fan
questions, Christof gets an angry call from Sylvia
Garland, who berates him for imprisoning Truman
without his consent. Christof retorts by saying
that the real world is the actual prison while
the “cell” Truman lives in gives him the chance
to lead a completely normal life, free of violence
or pain. He finishes by adding that Truman is
free to leave should he discover the truth.
The next day, Truman seems to
have gone back to his normal
self. However, Meryl leaves him because of his
paranoid behavior. At work, he is introduced
to a new coworker named Vivien, appointed by
Christof as Truman’s prospective female partner.
Later that evening, Truman falls asleep in a
makeshift bed in his basement while organizing
things. After several hours of inactivity,
Christof grows worried and orders the crew to ring
Truman’s phone. However, Truman doesn’t answer,
much less move. Christof then sends Marlon over to
his home with a pack of beer. Christof guides him
to the basement, and to everyone’s astonishment,
it is revealed that Truman is absent from his bed.
Marlon then discovers a large hole in the basement
leading to the lawn. Truman has managed to
escape. With nothing to show to the audience,
Christof cuts the live transmission for the
first time ever in the history of the show.
The cease in the transmission of the iconic show
sends shockwaves around the world. Pressure from
fans, media, investors, and sponsors is kicking
Christof’s ass. He orders the entire staff,
including the extra actors, to go on a manhunt.
However, the actors find it hard to find a man
in the dark. So, Christof orders the sun to
rise well before the actual time of sunrise
to aid in Truman’s search. After searching every
inch of the land, Christof’s intuition tells him
to check the sea surrounding the island. It works,
and the cameras spot Truman on a sailboat with
a picture of Sylvia. The live transmission
is again resumed. At home, Sylva is elated
to see Truman trying to find the truth.
Christof orders the ferry captain to fetch
Truman but being just an actor; he doesn’t know
how to man a boat. Left with no other choice,
Christof simulates a storm to force Truman to go
back to port. Christof leaves no stone unturned to
scare Truman, but he puts up a fight and defiantly
yells at the sky, “Is that the best you can do?
You are gonna have to kill me.”
Enraged, Christoff sends sea wave after sea
wave to break Truman, almost capsizing the boat
and nearly drowning Truman. Christof realizes that
Truman would rather die than concede and allows
the sky to clear. Truman continues to sail away.
Soon, his boat is rocked by a strong impact.
Truman learns that his boat has collided with the
sky wall. He has reached the end of the dome. He
breaks into tears of joy. Walking on the edge of
the sky, he reaches a staircase leading to an exit
door. As he proceeds to exit, Christof finally
speaks to Truman through the intercom and informs
him that he is the star of a reality TV show
called “The Truman Show.” He tries to convince
Truman to continue to live on his fantasy island
as Sylvia and the entire world watch
intently on their TV set. Christof tells him,
“There's no more truth out there in the world than
I created for you. The same lies. The same deceit.
But in my world you have nothing to fear. ”
After some deliberation, Truman looks up at the
sky and says, “In case I don't see you, good
afternoon, good evening, and good night.”
before bowing and leaving. An elated Sylvia
rushes out of her apartment in excitement
as the rest of the world erupts in cheers and
happiness at the finale of the Truman Show.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like
to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.